JON, BACK TO YOU.
>> Jon: STEVE, THANK YOU.
>> Julie: BLACK FRIDAY AND
CYBER MONDAY MAY BE GETTING
MOST OF THE HOLIDAY GIFTING
FOCUS.
SMALL BUSINESS SATURDAY TAKES
ON A WHOLE NEW IMPORTANCE.
MANY BUSINESSES STRUGGLE TO
STAY AFLOAT.
CHERYL CASONE FROM FOX BUSINESS
JOINS US NOW.
IT HAS BEEN A DIFFICULT YEAR,
THE MOST DIFFICULT YEAR IN MANY
OF THESE SMALL BUSINESS’S
HISTORY.
THEY ARE OEF ABOUT TO HAVE A
HOPEFUL -- MAYBE HOPEFUL MORE
UPBEAT MOMENT IN THE SPOTLIGHT.
WE WOULD LIKE GOOD NEWS.
>> THE MORE WE TALK ABOUT IT
THE BETTER IT WILL BE FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES.
64% OF SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS
SAY TOMORROW IS MAKE OR BREAK
FOR THEM.
THEY REALLY ARE DEPENDING ON
THE REVENUE TO COME IN.
SHOPPERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
NEED TO SUPPORT THE SMALL
BUSINESSES TOMORROW.
I HOPE IT HAPPENS BECAUSE LAST
YEAR AMERICANS SPENT NEARLY $20
BILLION ON SMALL BUSINESS
SATURDAY.
THIS IS THE 11th YEAR THAT
WE’VE HAD SMALL BUSINESS
SATURDAY AND AT THIS POINT THAT
PPP MONEY THAT THESE GUYS GOT,
THE SMALL MOM AND POP SHOPS
DIDN’T LAST VERY LONG.
WE KNOW THAT.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE A HUGE DRIVER OF
GROWTH FOR JOBS IN THIS COUNTRY.
IT IS NOT JUST ABOUT THE
BUSINESS OWNERS, IT IS ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THAT WORK FOR THE
SMALL BUSINESSES AND THIS YEAR
MORE THAN EVER IT IS CRUCIAL WE
DO THAT.
I WILL SAY ONE THING TO
ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO GO TO A
SMALL BUSINESS TOMORROW.
IF YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT GOING
TO A MALL BECAUSE OF THE
CORONAVIRUS AND GETTING EXPOSED.
SMALL BUSINESSES, MANY ACROSS
THE COUNTRY HAVE SAFETY
MEASURES IN PLACE THAT LIMIT
CAPACITY BUT IN A SMALL STORE
THAT CAN BE A GOOD THING AND
MAYBE PEOPLE WILL FEEL MORE
SAFE TO WALK INTO THAT SHOP.
>> Julie: I WANT TO PUT THE
NUMBERS INTO PERSPECTIVE FOR
OUR VIEWERS.
IF YOU LOOK AT SMALL BUSINESS
CLOSURES FROM MARCH 1 WHEN THE
PANDEMIC ESSENTIALLY STARTED
HERE IN THE UNITED STATES TO
AUGUST 31 NEARLY 164,000 SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE CLOSED DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC.
AND ALSO TO GIVE YOU AN IDEA OF
HOW CRITICAL SMALL BUSINESSES
ARE TO AMERICANS.
OF THE 31.7 MILLION SMALL
BUSINESSES NATIONWIDE, THEY
EMPLOY 47.1% OF THE PRIVATE
SECTOR CREATING 1.6 MILLION
JOBS IN 2019.
AS WE LOOK AHEAD, WHAT DO YOU
BELIEVE 2021 WILL LOOK LIKE FOR
SMALL BUSINESS?
>> IT DEPENDS ON VACCINE
DISTRIBUTION.
IT DEPENDS ON THE ECONOMY AND
JOBS COMING BACK WHETHER IT’S
SMALL OR LARGE BUSINESSES.
IF YOU WORK FOR A LARGER
CORPORATION YOU HAVE MONEY TO
SPEND ON THE SMALL BUSINESS.
THE BIGGEST QUESTION MARK IS
GOING TO BE HOW SEVERE THESE
NEW ROUNDS OF LOCKDOWNS WILL BE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IT IS STILL STATE BY STATE.
THAT’S TOUGH FOR ECONOMISTS AND
ANALYSTS TO QUANTIFY.
I CAN SAY THAT IF THESE
LOCKDOWNS CONTINUE INTO
JANUARY, THAT PUTS THEM AT A
DISADVANTAGE IN THE BEGINNING
OF THE YEAR.
HAVING SAID THAT I WILL SAY
WE’RE SEEING A LOT OF PENT-UP
DEMAND UP THERE FOR FOLKS
ANXIOUS TO GO OUT AND SPEND.
ANXIOUS TO GET BACK TO THE
RESTAURANT AND THEIR GYM AND
THEIR FRIENDS AND FAMILY AND
HAVING A SOCIAL LIFE.
WE’RE SEEING THAT IN NEW YORK.
I WAS LOOKING AT UNEMPLOYMENT
IN THE CITY.
IT IS 14 1/2% RIGHT NOW.
THERE ARE STORES ACROSS THE
CITY, JULIE, AS YOU KNOW, YOU
LIVE HERE, TOO, THAT ARE
SHUTTERED AND OUT OF BUSINESS.
FIRST LET’S GET THIS VACCINE
DISTRIBUTED AND GET IT OUT
THERE, WHICH PROBABLY MARCH OR
APRIL BEFORE IT WILL BE MORE
RAMPANT.
ALSO LET’S ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO
GET BACK OUT AND SUPPORT THESE
SMALL BUSINESSES.
THERE IS A LOT OF STEPS WE HAVE
TO GET TO.
I WILL SAY ANOTHER ROUND OF PPP
WOULD BE GREAT.
THAT COULD REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE.
GIVE THESE GUYS A LIFELINE TO
HANG ON UNTIL 2021.
>> Julie: THE 11th ANNUAL SMALL
BUSINESS SATURDAY IS TOMORROW.
GIVE BACK TO YOUR LOCAL
BUSINESSES.
THEY NEED IT MORE NOW MORE THAN